Morsi appeared in public for the first
time since he was deposed on July third
Egyptian state television showed him
arriving at the court with a time delay
and with no sound apparently so the
cheers of his supporters could not be
heard morsi's gesture of defiance was
quickly cut off the former president
seems undaunted despite a rule requiring
white prison garb Morsi unlike his 14
co-defendants wore a suit when the
presiding judge objected scuffles broke
out in the courtroom the trial was
postponed one of morsi's lawyers
described his statement to the court
while the president said that he rejects
the military coup that he rejects the
court and that he rejects the legitimacy
of the prosecutor general Muslim well
thought of a Martha Morsi is charged
with incitement to murder related to
events last December while he was still
president clashes outside the
presidential palace left at least 10
people dead all of them said to be
opponents of the Muslim Brotherhood
prosecutors accuse Morsi of coordinating
the Islamist groups behind the attacks
his defense team has criticized his
treatment
it's not just Morsi supporters who have
doubts about the legality of his ouster
the international community has
expressed concern that the Army's
crackdown on the Muslim Brotherhood
means Egypt could revert to a police
state